US investigators are saying more about
the motives for the Russian hacking they
believe political campaigns were not the
only targets for Vladimir Putin and his
intelligence service Jeff the gaze is
talking with his sources about the
Russian operation that began in the
summer of last year Jeff good morning
good morning investigators believe the
cyber attacks that affected the
Democratic National Committee are part
of an elaborate Russian cyber espionage
operation US intelligence officials have
warned for some time that Russian
officials have been working to carry out
cyber operations that cause political
instability or even regime change
investigators now believe that Vladimir
Putin initially wanted to damage Hillary
Clinton with the cyber attacks I've
stood up to Russia and to inject chaos
and out into the u.s. election process
they've also decided who they want to
see become president the United States
to when it's not me wow what a crowd US
officials say it was an added bonus the
Donald Trump seen as more friendly to
rush an interest became the Republican
nominee would it be nice if we actually
got along with Russia the information
investigators now have comes from a
variety of sources and shows that
hundreds of people may have been
involved from the Kremlin to Russian
intelligence and to hacking units they
weren't just trying to get lucky and
while a lectin Trump definitely benefits
them they also win even if Clinton is
elected because she would be weakened
her her mandate to govern would be we
can buy all of the negative feedback
that's been put into the media system
Clint watts is a fellow at the Center
for cyber and homeland security at
George Washington University rather than
negotiating at a state to state level
they're actually engaging the US public
to try and influence an outcome that
they want the election process was not
the only target for Russian hackers the
American military was targeted in July
of 2015 when the unclassified email
system of the pentagon's joint staff was
breached CBS News national security
correspondent David Martin reports the
retired chairman of the Joint Chiefs
martin Dempsey says the attack occurred
at an alarming speed within an hour
hackers had seized control of the
computer credentials of Dempsey and
hundreds of
they're senior officers the only way to
stop the attack was to take down the
computer network the hack came from
30,000 emails that were sent to a West
Coast University four were forded
forwarded to members of the Joint Staff
one was open the apparent purpose was to
cause damage and force the Pentagon to
replace their hardware and software
investigators believe the Russians were
lashing out after the Obama
administration imposed economic
sanctions Charlie hey thanks Jeff